[Music]
politicians are elected to represent us
they are here to protect our interests
over their political interests
refusal to try to work toward compromise
is putting politics over people
now president trump has been at the
white house virtually every day
working and waiting and trying to make a
deal
bending compromising and offering
solutions
they not only disrespect him they
sometimes
don't even show up they've refused his
every overture
put a stake in the ground proving that
politics are more important
than putting people back to work and
as eight hundred thousand federal
employees face the loss
of a second paycheck this tuesday the
democrats
disregard their distress by not
negotiating to the to end the partial
government shutdown
and that my friends is a problem
but it's even bigger they refuse to
negotiate for people who live
paycheck to paycheck they don't consider
americans whose lives safety
economy and social service agencies
are drained by these uninvited illegals
today the president offered yet another
compromise to reopen the government
there will be no concrete wall
only steel slat barriers 5.7 billion
dollars for it
805 million for drug detection
technology
800 million for humanitarian assistance
almost 3 000 additional border patrol
agents
75 new immigration judges and a
three-year extension for tps and daca
the president described in clear and
direct language
the human crises ranging from 300 of
our children dying every week from
heroin
90 percent of which comes through those
porous
mexican borders now young people
can seek asylum in their country without
traveling with those dangerous human
traffickers and coyotes
he talked about what many of us in law
enforcement already knew
that parents give their daughters birth
control pills
knowing full well that their daughters
will be raped along this
dangerous journey and the knee-jerk
reactions
are in nancy pelosi
calls the president's proposals
unacceptable and said
what's original in his proposal is not
good
and what's good in his proposal is not
original
chuck schumer called it one-sided and
ineffective
no surprise democrats
demon rats are dug into the theater
of lies and hate casting donald trump as
evil while casting themselves as angels
supported by a mainstream media intent
on publishing
any anti-trump story however baseless
or absurd journalistic standards
be damned the theater was actually
brought to the absurd
when nancy pelosi sent a letter to the
president
saying it was too dangerous for him to
give the state of the union speech
saying she didn't want him telling his
lies and distortions
in the house a typical example by the
way of what the left is doing in general
shut down the voice of the president
shut down
law and order shut down security
at our border turns out nancy
you never even spoke to security in fact
every day congress is in session
nobody's been shut down for lack of
security
admit it you made it up to shut them
down
but never in the history of this great
nation
has a speaker refused the president the
opportunity
to give a state of the union address and
of course
not one to be cowed the president pulls
you off a government bus
30 minutes before your trip to europe
nancy what the hell were you doing
boarding a
bus with your democrat cronies
on the way to brussels to meet with nato
leaders
there's a partial government shutdown we
don't need you in brussels
how do you negotiate your way out of a
stalemate
while you're on a seven-day european
excursion
that we the taxpayers pay for
you got some hutzpah lady
and what were you going to do have
another few parties on our
dime and bad mouth the president to
those who prefer
that we foot their nato bill to
and then you and your band of friendlies
off then to afghanistan
to find out what's going on from the
troops on the ground
really you think some soldier is going
to
saunter up and whisper in your ear to
give you the real
scoop when his bosses at the pentagon
would be happy to do so in washington
or is it that you think the troops are
dying to see you
send them a video nancy and thank them
and by the way is this how you reinforce
your power base by approving trips
are you the premier congressional junket
organizer
but then again you've never been one to
sacrifice
how are you how about instead of the
trips you
estro that money for federal employees
what's that you'd rather not
because polling blames trump for the
shutdown and you're
good with that and by the way nancy
so is he he's wearing his big boy pants
and he offered to take the burden
just to get it done how about since
you're in charge of all spending bills
nancy you forgo
your check until this is over
man up like the federal employees going
through the shutdown
donate congressional salaries to those
who won't get one
after all reports are you and your
husband are worth over 100 million
dollars
how did you make that money nancy how
long is it that you've been in congress
now president trump he hasn't taken a
check
he's donated his salary since day one
to a number of federal agencies and
nancy
this is just the two of us here talking
admit it
you're big donors in california they
want
illegals to pick grapes even cesar
chavez
you're old enough to remember him fought
tooth and nail to stop
illegal immigrants to protect legal
immigrants
and the farm workers it's all
theater folks the president they say is
a fear-monger
this is a manufactured crisis
say that to the face of an angel mom
whose child was murdered or massacred by
illegal immigrants you have kids nancy
you do don't you and why did you
approve securing the 2000 of the border
like so many of your democrat cronies in
2006
and 13 under the secure fence act but
not
this the obvious answer
because donald trump wants it instead
your
path is to disrespect americans
and instead respect those who violate
our laws
while you and your ilk praise pictures
of raised pictures of furloughed fellow
federal employees
when you won't meet with the angel moms
who come to your office
with pictures of american children
killed by
illegals so let me see if i understand
this
an american mother shows a picture of a
child
murdered by an illegal and chuck schumer
and his
gang they come out and show pictures of
federal employees is there a
moral equivalency here are you folk
schizo are you working for
americans or illegals or is it that you
just don't
give a damn you vacation in hawaii
your buddies vacation with lobbyists in
puerto rico during the shutdown
and you plan a jaunt to europe while
federal employees
are trying to save every dollar to buy
groceries
admit it you don't give a damn
nancy you're a hypocrite a political
operative
your mantra destroy the president of the
united states
to hell with the tax paying hard-working
americans
let them eat cake i've got a junket to
go on
an ego to assuage and an electorate to
ignore
and nancy if you're too afraid to take a
commercial flight
there are alternate ways to fly
check this one out it's tailor made
for you
and that's my open